le fait du jour c'est donc qu'elle la
colère qui gronde attrape après le choix
de la municipalité d'adopter dès le mois
de septembre les nouveaux rythmes
scolaires trapel la plus importante
commune des yvelines à avoir fait ce
choix elles ne sont en tout que huit
d'ailleurs sur les 262 que compte le
département dont soir michel valentin
enseignant à l'école maternelle renoir
et luc miserait secrétaire de la section
locale du parti communiste et merci
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation je
précise que la municipalité était
conviée ce soir mais qu'elle n'a pas
donné suite à notre demande vous allez
nous expliquer pourquoi vous êtes contre
7,7 réforme cette mise en place dès 2013
pour l'instant retour sur cette réunion
qui s'est tenue hier soir sur la commune
la ville de trappes avait prévu une
réunion publique de restitution des
travaux
mais le maire a préféré y mettre fin
après quelques minutes julie rocha
soares elodie moines pour les images
mercredi une réunion publique de
restitution des travaux sur les rythmes
de l'enfant était organisée à trappes
pour l'occasion un comité d'accueil
particulier attendait le maire devant
l'auditorium de musique et de danse
plusieurs centaines de manifestants
remontés contre les mises en place de la
semaine de quatre jours et demi dans les
écoles de la commune dès 2013 à
l'intérieur le climat étrange dans le
public quelques parents soucieux
d'obtenir des réponses sur
l'organisation à anticiper pour la
rentrée et surtout une majorité de
protestataires venus revendiquer
certaines décisions prises selon le soin
concertation ce qui nous gêne le plus
c'est que la philosophie de cette
refondation s'était proposé des
activités de recevoir une subvention de
l'état pour que les enfants puissent
s'ouvrir à autre chose et que dans la
danse qui proposait par le mr bah oui 3
la subvention puisque ils votent pour
2013 et à aucun moment il ya des
propositions qui sont faites par les
enfants
ce que j'aimerais c'est qu'on ait le
temps de discuter qu'on est temps de se
concerter tous ensemble autour d'une
table et qu'on prenne les décisions en
rom en resituant en remettant l'enfant
au centre des débats et non pas
uniquement des points techniques ou
financiers la fcpe locale qui sur ce
dossier apparaît divisée absolument
regrettable que les enseignants n'ai
rien voulu entendre moi personnellement
je me sens pas du tout représentés par
des gens qui sifflent comme ça et que
refuse le débat d'une certaine façon
puisqu'il n'était pas non plus présent
lors de la consultation
après cinq minutes de présentation des
travaux de la consultation par un agent
municipal le maire décide de mettre fin
à la règle
m
l'important c'est qu'est ce qu'on
construit pour les enfants et nous avons
nous sommes en train de construire pour
la ville quelque chose d'intéressant
prison qui va jusqu'à mettre beaucoup
d'argent à investir un plan de 50
modification des écoles sur et la
formation des éducateurs
la réunion ne sera pas reportée quant à
la réforme allait maintenu à la rentrée
prochaine pour un coût estimé
annuellement entre 500 et 600 millions
euros pour la municipalité 36 écoles et
4200 élèves sont concernés
la réforme sera en place dès le mois de
septembre le maire ne changera pas
d'avis malgré la mobilisation d'hier
soir des opposants finalement la
manifestation n'aura servi à rien
liquidret ben si elle a réussi à
exprimer le déni de démocratie qui se
passe c'est à dire que sur le fond ici à
personne et dehors non plus qui est
contre cette réforme cette réforme est
indispensable faut rappeler que c'est la
majorité ump avec monsieur darcos qui
avait ramené la semaine à quatre jours
qui est une erreur fondamentale par
rapport à l'intérêt des enfants et donc
tout le monde est d'accord là dessus
simplement tout le monde souhaiterait
que ça se fasse dans de bonnes
conditions
or aussi bien le ministre vincent
peillon n'a pas consulté suffisamment
alors on nous dit s'il a consulté oui
ils sont consultés nous ont dit quand on
veut qu'une réforme réussissent parce
que l'objet c'est bien ça il faut
chercher à associer plus largement
possible les parents d'élèves les
enseignants également les animateurs
municipaux qui ces animations sur ce
temps libre à larguer les gens qui
seront amenés
à intervenir sur ce champ là or pour
faire cela et pour véritablement que les
gens s'impliquent
il faut prendre le temps d'une véritable
concertation et c'est pas ce qui se
passe là c'est regrettable
du côté des enseignants en ce qui vous
concerne vous avez eu le sentiment
d'être entendu écouté en tout cas on n'a
jamais été entendu ni écoutés on a pris
les choses en main on a fait un
questionnaire a fait parvenir à tous les
enseignants de trappes de mémoire sur
les 232 enseignants qui ont répondu 230
se sont prononcés pour le report en 2014
tous les conseils d'école ont voté le
report votée par les enseignants mais
aussi par les parents et aussi certains
représentants mairie mais quand vous
entendez par exemple dans le reportage
et à des représentants de la des parents
d'élèves de la fcpe ça ne fait pas
l'unanimité du côté de la fcpe qui
disent qu'ils ne se sentaient pas
représentés par les ailes et sifflements
qui ont été entendus hier dans la salle
la situation de la fcpe à trappes est un
peu particulière c'est à dire qu'il ya
semble-t-il des tensions à l'intérieur
il ya deux trois personnes qui sont qui
sont plus favorables à 2013 et une
grosse pour vous les personnes qui
soutiennent cette mise en place en 2013
que ce soit ou non des représentants
syndiqués de parents d'élèves même chose
pour les enseignants d'ailleurs
syndiqués ou non comme c'est votre cas
sont contre la mise en place en 2013
oui il la majorité est contre
l'application de but précis très clair
c'est très net tous les conseils d'école
se sont prononcés pour 2014 l'ensemble
des enseignants se sont prononcés pour
c'est très clair mais pourquoi tout
simplement expliqué mme quel est le fond
votre pensée qu'est ce qui motive ce
refus de cette mise en place d une très
grande le temps il faut il faut prendre
le temps pour quoi ça servirait soient
concertés autant faim pour réfléchir à
comment organiser la journée sur
l'instance j'irai vers une journée qui
débutera à 9 heures le matin à 8h30 ce
qui fait une demi heure en moins par
jour
oui c'est ça ferait deux heures par
semaine on our les ombres pas l'intérêt
animateurs seulement on n'en voit pas
l'intérêt en tant qu'enseignante vois
pas l'intérêt vous en avez discuté déjà
justement avec des parures
c'est leur enfance sortie des écoles qui
a posé problème des parents bien sûr
puisqu'il ya de nombreux parents qui
sont pas tous chômeurs attraper quelques
uns qui peuvent et ceux qui bossent ils
sont pas très contents
je miserai pour vous l'intérêt pour la
commune il est financier c'est
uniquement le financier alors qu'ils
prennent dans cette histoire je pense
vraisemblablement que ça a été un des
critères majeurs qui a été retenu alors
il faut pas nier ce qui est une évidence
la ville s'implique beaucoup sur ce
secteur mais on pourrait penser qu'elle
pouvait faire d'avantagé au niveau de
cette concertation qui évoquait encore
une fois si on veut que ça réussisse ce
qu'il ya les horaires mais y'a pas
simplement que les horaires mais déjà
les horaires c'est important parce
qu'elle sent ça dans une ville comme
trappe de commencer à 9 heures
qu'est ce que ça veut dire c'est à dire
que les enfants ils vont rester plus
devant la télé à regarder les dessins
animés des enfants pour être les
récupérer derrière pour l'heure
d'accueil du matin ça ne changera pas ce
serait toujours aux alentours de 7h30
d'accord mais il y en a certains qui
vont rester plus longtemps devant la
télé pour les récupérer derrière sur un
travail d'enseignement ça va être un peu
plus compliqué donc la problématique
c'est aussi que l'état se désengage dans
cette affaire parce qu'en fait il fait
la réforme et il dit aux collectivités
territoriales pour l'essentiel vous
allez payer parce que l'aide
elle est sur deux ans mais derrière pour
les communes qui ce qui le met en place
des douanes à 13 voilà mais derrière
vous à les assumer les c'est l'état qui
doit assumer ses les toits qui doit
assumer à partir du moment et fait une
modification il doit assumer alors après
il ya le grand discours la dette etc
bon en même temps qu'ils à la dette il
ya les milliardaires qui sont toujours
plus nombreux il y a
le fait que cette évasion fiscale
pourraient être utilisées donc il ya des
moyens est ce qu'on fait tous j'en suis
pas convaincu donc les moyens existent
c'est simplement des choix politiques
qu'il faut faire ça à côté justement là
on rentre véritablement dans des
discussions politiques un véritable bien
sûr de fond d'opposition ça veut dire
que vos relations avec la municipalité
au parti communiste au front de gauche
se sont compliquées avec la municipalité
socialiste
les relations sont compliquées en termes
de démocratie
on vient d'avoir deux conseillers
municipaux qui sont fait retirer leur
délégation d'autorité par monsieur le
maire donc les réalisations sont
compliquées il n'enlève rien au fait qu'
il ya un engagement de cette
municipalité dans le cadre de
l'éducation
simplement nous on pense que ça pourrait
se faire d'une autre manière et que
trappes est composé de beaucoup de
jeunes et de jeunes enfants et que ça
mérite qu'on s'y attache d'une manière
un petit peu différente si on veut que
cette réforme réussissent et et elle est
faite pour réussir il faut prendre le
temps d'installer correctement les
choses
or là si on est obligé d'annuler une
réunion comme ça c'est que c'est un
sentiment de frustration d'une immense
majorité
bon cette personne responsable de la
fcpe est honorable on entendu tout à
l'heure dans le reportage
elle a tout à fait le droit de défendre
la politique de monsieur le maire 1
mais à partir de là c'est manifestement
pas l'opinion d'une majorité de parents
d'enseignants d'animateur et de
personnes qui vont devoir intervenir sur
un champ où à partir du moment où
l'enjeu c'est l'enfant il son
développement intellectuel et social
c'est un enjeu extrêmement important
vous étiez mobilisés hier aussi bien
avec le parti communiste des
représentants politiques des enseignants
tout simplement qu'ils sont venus à se
mobiliser lors de la présentation du
projet par le maire la suite de votre
action maintenant ce sera quoi
demain une assemblée générale on espère
être encore plus nombreux et l'état
d'esprit c'est que c'est pas la fin
c'est le début ça veut dire que les
dernières mais les derniers mois d'ici
aux vacances ne lâchera pas vous voulez
que ce soit reporté en 2014
le ch a peur tout à fait merci à tous
les deux je rappelle donc que trap a
fait le choix de 2013 4295 élèves
concernés par cette semaine de cours à 4
5 jours dans 36 écoles c'est la
principale commune du département à
avoir fait ce choix juste derrière elle
et muraux bonnière ou encore poissy